vu les problèmes qu'on a de
discrimination dans le monde étudiant
finalement je veux même pas voir ce que
ça va donner dans le monde du travail et
je veux pouvoir travailler enfin créer
mon emploi et adapter mon poste en fait
à moi même et ça du coup ça me fait un
objectif ses fils à 27 ans elle est
atteinte de déficience visuelle dut
informatique master 1 de japonais est
actuellement première année de licence
de gestion à lui vs q cela fait 9 ans
qu'elle apprend pas facile de jongler
avec les études quand on est malvoyant
fatigue visuelle importantes difficultés
de perception des détails ou encore de
déplacement un combat de tous les jours
on se repère avec le solde est différent
par rapport aux autres
en fait il ya les difficultés par
rapport aux études donc suivre les cours
prendre des notes réussir les examens
avant les aménagements et il ya aussi
les dix les difficultés liées aux
déplacements trouver les salles où on
accourt ne pas se tromper dans les
emplois du temps où parfois on n'arrive
pas à l'éliminer du conte se trouvent
dos reis trône de celle du coup c'est
assez pratique ici parce que dans cette
université il ya des accueils dans
chacun des bâtiments ce qui n'a pas dans
toutes les universités et ça quand on
trouve pas une salle c'est quand même
vraiment très pratique
olala
mal à ça c'est le genre de truc
qui est un peu compliqué parce que au
sol gelé détecte pas avec la can et je
sais pas que je peux passer du coup
si je pense
des petits pièges comme sa surprise
qu'elle veut pas calculer à chaque fois
alors normalement d'anciens est pas ici
un équilibre entre travail et fatigue
est pas toujours facile à trouver pour
aider les personnes en situation de
handicap l'université met en place des
aménagements comme cet ascenseur cécile
dispose également d'outils personnel une
canne pour les déplacements une loupe
électronique ou encore cet ipad qui lui
permet d'accéder à une synthèse vocale
et d'écrire en contraste inversé c'est
que mon texte est écrit en blanc sur
fond noir comme ça c'est beaucoup moins
éblouissant pour les yeux quand on passe
beaucoup de temps sur l'écran mais je
pense qu'il n'ya pas que les personnes
malvoyantes tranquille c'est confortable
c'est aussi un de mes cours que j'ai
tapé sous la dictée donc c'est pour ça
qu'il est assez complète quand les profs
ne font que dicte et moi c'est ce qu'ils
mangent le plus c'est que mes camarades
râle parce qu'ils aiment dire quand il
ya des choses écrites mois celle inverse
activé drive clientèle le type de
produits voilà il en fait il dit après
le court par le par exemple que j'ai
sélectionné
après je peux leur désactiver assez
passionnant quand j'ai eu besoin de lire
un texte est tout petit je peux cliquer
sur l'élément et le faire lire par
l'ipad font vraiment c'est assez
pratique cécile espère sensibiliser pour
faire comprendre son handicap
aujourd'hui le manque d'informations
dont disposent ses camarades impact sa
vie étudiante ne sachant pas comment
réagir ils n'osent pas venir vers elle
un regret pour la jeune femme pourtant
très sociable mes camarades à l'univers
sont bloqués par ça mais je pense pas
que ce soit forcément de la mauvaise
volonté ou c'est juste qu'ils savent pas
comment venir vers moi ils savent pas
comment s'adresser à moi je suis non
voyantes ou malvoyantes 6 et du coup je
suis très souvent tout seul et je pense
que c'est assez triste en fait de dire
moi j'adore échanger avec les gens
j'adore discuter et de se retrouver tout
seul tout le temps juste parce que les
gens ils savent pas on peut être un et
c'est vraiment dommage parce que quand
on est étudiant on va on est là aussi
pour échanger pour ou même juste aller
manger avec des gens quelque part allez
discuter des cours discuter et c'est
très rare que je puisse parler avec des
gens donc c'est un peu un peu dommage au
terme de ses études cécile a pour
objectif de créer sa propre entreprise
dans l'import de produits japonais